i don't know if it's because of my lack
of inex like experience of
being in situations like that or just
the fact that conventions have gotten so
much more calm
in the last like five years oh yeah or
it's a combination of both because
you don't hear that kind of [ __ ] like
last year right i mean i feel like
i feel like things are way more
regulated
now yeah usually because i remember
first time going to conventions
uh my like some of my first signings it
was kind of like anything goes
you know what i mean and like last year
they had like a ticketing system or
maybe was the year before that where
they had like a proper ticketing system
because i remember i'd be booked out
to do signings for like an hour and then
it would end up going for like two hours
and a half
yeah and and there was there was nothing
that like regulated what
what was okay and what wasn't it i guess
that's like the benefit of the big
conventions right is that yeah because
there are so many people
and they probably know how popular you
are they're like if
if your signing session is one hour then
it's [ __ ] one hour yeah and we're
cutting off
and i think also i think people it's
it's gotten more in people's ideas
on people's heads now that just because
you're at an anime convention
social norms still do exist because i
remember in the before time and i can't
imagine what it was
like even before i started going to
conventions but it seemed like going to
anime conventions just like all rules
fell out the window
you could get away with anything i mean
i watched footage of like anime expo at
like [ __ ]
2005 right and like you know that was
during like the whole like glomp
and like yeah
i can't imagine [ __ ] being there and
like staying sane i'm like i don't
i don't want to like walk through the
convention hall with the fear that a
random person is going to
jump dive at me because it's lol xd
it turns from like an anime convention
to like a survival horror
who's gonna who's gonna invade my
personal space now i'm like pressing
down on everyone right who's next i feel
like you just probably came from a place
of like
i mean i assumed that it was the one
time of the year where they would get to
meet anime fans
right right right and like outside of
that you probably didn't get to see them
right like
yeah but now i mean everyone's a [ __ ]
anime fan right that's right that's
i think that's what it is it's all it is
now is
everyone just goes to a place to buy
anime merch and get drunk together yeah
yeah yeah pretty much
so it's like i i understand that back
then
probably was a little over the top
because this is the only [ __ ] chance
you get to be a [ __ ] weep like
every other year of the day of the year
you can't be a wee but like yeah i i
feel like the golden period for me for
anime conventions where it was like
you got you could get away with things
that were like fun but
i feel like the point where i started to
get really really regulated was
around 2016 onwards-ish
because i mean as it should because
there's so much [ __ ] sketchy [ __ ]
happening in the background yeah
there was a lot of sketchy [ __ ] i mean
that was around the time when the whole
like cosplay isn't
concerned yeah which came which
definitely it's like why would you even
need to write that out
that like is a failure on humanity
which which we needed to implement this
rule yeah that's it's like oh yes i need
something written down on paper to know
that being overly sexual towards
cosplays is a bad thing yeah exactly
[ __ ] well i remember like uh i've
cause i've been going to london
mcm expo for like a fair few years now i
remember
uh i remember when they so to explain
london mcm expo it's like the biggest
kind of like
it's kind of pretty [ __ ] terrible
convention it's it's a convention in
inverted commerce because it's more like
an
it is an expo it just tells you stuff
and there's not really anything to do
there if you're like a fan
yeah it's kind of like you can buy stuff
and pretty much all anyone does is just
hang out with their friends
exactly so there's this grass bit in um
mc outside of the convention center
which everywhere used everywhere where
everyone used to hang out and now it's
closed off but i feel like some of my
best memories were when people were just
doing like the most random [ __ ]
on that grass all the alcohol bottles
yeah
dude were you there that year where
there was they they did that that fight
club
no okay is it a fight club yeah
so i don't know why the mental imager of
a bunch of weaves beating each other up
it's hilarious
it was it was a fight it was a fight
club but it was like a
fight club so it was like it was like
the equivalent of a mosh pit or
something like that
but i remember there was like you know
there was obviously the usual you know
you got the [ __ ] jedis dueling it out
but i remember
the funniest one i saw was um there was
these there was these two anime fans
and one was like the scrawniest shortest
anime fan who was like
vitamin d vitamin d deficient you know
you know you know
you know someone's you know that the
steroid that that's their
clearly sick dude yeah skeletal skeletal
and then on the other side was the
[ __ ]
biggest like he wasn't like obese but
let's say he was a he was a he was a big
lad yeah yeah yeah yeah
he was a big lap yeah and this was like
the most
uneven fight i had ever seen
like forget about weight classes here
you know
so i guess they just try to like make
each other fall over right so this this
scrawny this scoring dude
[ __ ] full-on sprints into this guy
trying to like push him
and he just [ __ ] bounces off him like
he's in like like he's playing four guys
or something right
then the guy just sits on him
that was the end of the fight are they
all drunk yes everyone was drunk
okay it just crushes the convention ends
at like
six but that area is still full of
people drinking yeah
it's just outside that sounds awesome i
would have i would love to be there
it's just a spectator it's kind of
fiesta it's kind of crazy
now but now it's like a lot more
controlled of what you can get away with
which
it's a bit of a shame because i i i
liked i liked that kind of thing
i was just literally like an off license
in a tesco within like 200 meters of it
so that's not good people are just
buying buying buying drinks drinks
drinks and it's like it's it's
it's i think the hotel headaches is
literally a hotel right outside right
like what are you doing why are you all
[ __ ] getting drunk why is this big
dude sitting on this scrawny kid
is there why is there a fight club why
are people cheering i think i think we
could i think it was that fight club
that made the convention actually
actually caught enough look at the grass
the grass area
it was worth it anyone who was at that
mcm convention knows that that fight
club was hilarious as [ __ ] yeah that
sounds [ __ ] awesome health and safety
issues aside
it is fun when you walk into trying to
make adventure and you see something
that clearly will get shut down within
an hour yeah
i'm just going to sit and watch this
this [ __ ] go down this is going to be
funny
i see that [ __ ] even regularly at anime
expo still to this day like outside of
the west wing you know where all the
cosplayers are yeah i see some [ __ ]
there where i'm just like
why why where are the staff who's
regulating this